das ist ein kurzer satz aber er dürfte
deutschlands gesundheitsminister bzw
pandemie minister karl lauterbach
ordentlich aufrütteln us präsident joe
biden hat die korona pandemie offiziell
für beendet erklärt
die pandemie ist vorbei wir haben zwar
immer noch ein problem mit krone und
haben viel arbeit vor uns aber die
pandemie ist vorbei die pandemie war
also vorbei ja damit schwenken die usa
auf die linie frankreichs einen dort
viele chor oder regeln nicht mehr im
kraft und das bereits seit ende august
in deutschland verharrt weiter im all -
wir haben beim gesundheitsminister
nachgefragt ist es also vorbei
lauterbach bewertet die krone lage ganz
anders auf bild anfrage erklärte ein
ministeriumssprecher wie die experten
rat rechnet die bundesregierung im
herbst weiterhin mit einer
mittelschweren welle sie kann immer noch
gefährlich seien besonders für
ungeimpfte und variable gruppen und sehr
bild meinung chef philipp ist jetzt bei
uns im studio schönen guten morgen herr
philip andere länder erklären die
pandemie für beendet aber wir wir machen
weiter wie kann es sein ja und das
schlimmste ist unser gesundheitsminister
kann nicht mehr adäquat auf joe biden
reagieren er ist jetzt
gesundheitsminister und kann nicht
einfach mal so drauflos twittern wenn
ein us-präsident da sagt wir können uns
glaube ich alle vorstellen wie es karl
lauterbach in den fingern juckte wie er
sein handy schon in der hand hatte
twitter geöffnet und ein
ministeriumssprecher funkel ich sagte
herr minister sie dürfen das nicht
machen das ist der us-präsident sie
können hier keine regierungskrise
auslösen aber klar karl lauterbach sieht
das natürlich grundlegend anders da wird
corona noch eine ganze weile glaube ich
nicht vorbei sein also den satz die
pandemie ist vorbei den wird er so
schnell nicht sagen wir merken dass
janka lauterbach der twittert jeden tag
dazu der sagt jeden tag dazu irgendetwas
neues sagt wie wichtig ist es dass wir
die maßnahmen einführen er sagt ohne
seine maßnahmen würden die deutschen wie
das kaninchen vor der schlange sitzen
also wehrlos sozusagen ausgeliefert vor
den furchtbaren kona welle die uns da
erwartet aber ich glaube die wahrheit
liegt mehr bei dem was joe biden erklärt
corona ist natürlich da aber die groß
pandemische bedrohungslage die existiert
wohl eher nicht mehr im stopp sei dank
und auch omikron sei dank die konsequenz
der maßnahmen beziehungsweise die
inkonsequenz zeigt sich auch daran wenn
ich jetzt mit dem zug zum oktoberfest
nach münchen fahren möchte muss ich
maske tragen wenn ich dann dort auf der
wiesn ankomme keine maske mehr und die
leute feiern ausgelassen in bierzelten
wie passt das ganze zusammen erhöht sich
nicht jetzt auch der druck auf
lauterbach eben auch wenn andere staaten
sagen wir lassen die maßnahmen fallen
ja dass du hast perfekt beschrieben es
gibt da überhaupt keinen sinn mehr mit
dem zug maskiert zum oktoberfest zu
fahren und dort teil gelangen völlig zu
recht zu feiern und keine masken zu
tragen
eigentlich wäre es nur sinnvoll die
masten pflicht auf dem zukauf zu heben
aber unsere politiker machen ja vor wie
es mit der doppelmoral geht man geht zum
oktoberfest stellt sich ins volle zelt
prostet sich zu hat eine ganz tolle zeit
und dann steht man wieder mit besorgter
miene in berlin und seite müssten jetzt
alle aufeinander achtgeben und bitte
tragt doch die maske philipp iata für
über den corona irrsinn hierzulande
darin andere länder die pandemie für
beendet erklären danke für deinen besuch
im studio
[Musik]